our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy
what are we
what do we stand for I feel like most
Star Wars fans grow up going like this
like pretending to use the force and
especially at the supermarket yes 100
yes exactly and because I love the force
so much I wanted to start off by asking
you guys about it how is grogu's
relationship with the force change since
season two and is it still gonna be like
a strong part of his identity well he's
now trained with Luke Skywalker for a
certain amount of time and we know that
he already has some really good natural
ability and there's also stuff that he
learned before long ago that uh part of
it he remembers part of it he doesn't so
there is an unlocking of that so as we
meet grogu this year he definitely is
not the same you know not in the same
position that he was where it was a
little sporadic now because the force
using the forces is partially about
ability but a lot of it's about training
and about learning to control it and so
as he gets older and more mature as he
becomes more acclimated and more
comfortable in the relationship with the
Mandalorian and as you received training
from the greatest teacher around we're
going to see that he is evolving Dave I
wanted to ask you about the dark saber
because it's this weapon that a lot of
us don't know about and the coolest part
to me is that it attunes to the user's
emotional state which is so dope
um can you kind of quickly explain the
significance of the darksaber in the
Star Wars universe and how it relates to
din jarin's search for Redemption sure
the dark saver is saying that George
Lucas created way back when we were
working on Clone Wars
who was a Mandalorian uh was fighting
Obi-Wan Kenobi and had a what we would
call A vibroblade A different kind of
sword fighting a lightsaber and George
thought about that and said no we
shouldn't have a another sword that can
compete with the lightsaber so he
invented the darksaber something that
was unique uh in Star Wars something
that had been created long ago and taken
from the Jedi Temple and then we
expanded its lore to include the idea
that it was a sword created by the first
Mandalorian who was trained in the ways
of the Jedi and someone that could kind
of be a crossover between the two types
of training and knowledge and so the
dark save is really unique there hasn't
been another blade that's negative like
that it's also unique property it's
unlike a lightsaber which is a rounded
beam of energy it's a very flat blade of
energy so it has a much sharper more
dangerous edge as you could say in a lot
of ways and it feels more volatile so I
think all of that is just
to make it a story thing about
mandalorians themselves and how warlike
they are and how they've had a lot of
Conquest in their history but like
anything in order to wield it you have
to have training you have to have
discipline you can't just wield it you
know through pure might it's gonna you
know not work for you as well it's like
Excalibur that way you have to be the
The Once and Future King if you're going
to be able to pull the sword from the
stone so there are elements of that and
how it falls from hand to hand is also
becomes very important and we've also
seen that the strongest people it seems
even heavier to them and the Mandalorian
we've seen him use it Ginger and use it
he's injured himself it's not it's if
anything it's getting in the way because
he's so good at every weapon then we saw
uh Paz visually trying to use it after
he grabbed it and it seems to be a
hindrance to most people and even as far
back as in Rebels we saw training with
it seeing that it's heavy sometimes it's
heavy and sometimes it's light depending
on if you're destined to use it or if
you have training yeah or you're
emotionally where you are emotionally
and I love the high pitch of it I mean
few weapons have like as long and story
to history as the dark saber of
Mandalore I'm so excited for season
three because we're finally getting a
live action Mandalore when you were
creating this world what was so exciting
about Mandalore and its culture that you
were like so stoked to see on screen
well I love what they established in the
Clone Wars where even when you first go
there it's a mess it's it's desert it's
Dome cities because they've been
fighting and fighting and fighting and
even though we catch them in a moment of
peacefulness uh it's that's an outlier
to their history and it seems that this
war-like culture as effective as they
are when facing others
they fight each other internally as well
and I thought that that was a great
metaphor of what what a shortcoming that
is that you could be as strong as you
could be the most Mighty civilization
but if you can't cooperate and get along
You're vulnerable and ultimately doomed
so it's an interesting cautionary tale
that they established and we just we
just built upon
how many mandalorians are we gonna get
to see is it more and more than we have
before normal yeah quite a bit you know
thanks to you know thanks to our
ilm and also what we're able to film
customers and what we've established
already we we definitely um felt that it
was time for us to start putting some of
those chess pieces on the board we just
alluded to it and so now we're going to
be culminating in many ways oh it's so
cool just I'm sure for you guys it's so
cool to see things going from the page
to them like walking in and being
actualized like I can't even imagine
what that feeling is it's a bit surreal
yeah it's it's probably so cool
um I wanted to know because I asked
Pedro at d23 if he would ever want to
see this series end with a film and he
said yes it's a great idea and if it
isn't a conversation now it will be
after today and I wanted to know I
wanted to ask you guys the same question
I think part of what's nice about
storytelling now is that the rules there
are no rules I mean before we started
this there was no there wasn't the same
kind of presence in the streaming
ecosystem he had Netflix films or you
had films that were done for cable but
to have like a Disney First Disney Plus
show of this of this scope gave us a lot
of Storytelling opportunities and I
think we've seen from other examples I
think you see with Marvel how it goes
back and forth that you could move
between both media there's definitely an
opportunity the question becomes In This
Moment In Time about what the audience
wants you know how we apply our efforts
in our time because both take a lot of
time we're able to bring the the window
of of creating and delivering to about a
year so that we could keep hitting the
Cadence of a television show well with a
movie It Takes quite a bit longer and we
have to make sure we have a great story
that we could tell from the big screen
but certainly uh we're open to all
possibilities and we'll see where things
go I think the industry is going through
transitions now the entertainment
industry as well as in know what the
fans want from Star Wars and I think
we're going to learn a lot now with not
just this but as Ahsoka comes out and
skeleton crew and we'll see how all of
it works together and we'll understand
what connects Us best with our audience
well as a Latina you mentioned Ahsoka
this is like the most popular part of
Pop Culture where I think a lot of us
feel the most seen in between like Pedro
and Diego and Rosario Dawson you'd be
excited to see Rosario because she's
just great I love her like it we we
couldn't have done it every day on set I
got to tell you from morning to night no
matter how hard we're working she is the
the force she is the source of
inspiration uh and you know
she's just the best I can I'm so excited
for people to see it because of her and
what everybody's contributing but yeah
you you're right to be excited because
of Roe she's a Dynamo